maybe you can entertain the uh
holding hands problem that we've been
discussing here in the lab
so um imagine there is a row of people
and they all hold hands and
they just independently uh
are up or down right
so if there's but they all hold hands
like they can't let go
um so it's uniformly
which one like if this up or down and
what i want to know if there's n people
and i give you a number
m what's the fraction of times that
exactly
m people have both of their hands up
so if there's like 10 people and we go
through all combinations of this
what's the um what's the number of times
where exactly three people
have both of their hands up
it's not it's not as easy as it as it
sounds
yeah yeah i can undo this kind of
problem without writing it down
like it sounds like one of you know like
these kind of google interview questions
um
but we've been thinking about it and
it's it's either we are all
we're too dumb or and now i had to leave
but
probably when i go back people have
figured it out but i just thought it was
very interesting
okay well we're definitely going to
include that in the show so we'll see if
we get any
any takers welcome back to the machine
learning street talk youtube channel
this week is very special we have matild
carol from facebook she's coming to talk
to us
about one of her papers that she's just
published which is called
suave unsupervised learning of visual
features by contrasting cluster
assignments
now it was a really great conversation
today we got to find out all about
the kind of work that matilda has been
doing at facebook what her process is
how she came up with this algorithm and
how she published it
we're also joined today by ayush thakur
and
sayak paul from weights and biases they
have written an
amazing article going through matild's
paper and describing it and implementing
it
clearly matilda works for facebook and
the chief scientist at facebook is
yanderkoon
yan lacoon has this vision that
self-supervised learning is the future
in his presentation at iclr he sketched
out that
it's about predicting the future from
the past predicting
invisible from the visible predicting
occluded masked or corrupted parts from
available parts
pretending that there is an input which
you know about
so the idea is that self-supervised
learning allows you to learn
incredibly good and generalizable
representations
without needing to know any semantic
annotations for your data set
this is incredibly intriguing but one of
the things that we explore today is
how much of that is determined by the
amount of semantic information or the
structure of your data set in the first
place
how much of it is determined by the
algorithm now this is the latest in the
line of contrastive
unsupervised image algorithms the
contrastive loss
explicitly compares pairs of image
representations
to push away representations from
different images and to
squeeze together representations of
images that are semantically equivalent
now because comparing all of the pairs
of images in a data set together is
computationally intractable
many of the approaches in the literature
have worked on
reducing the images to groups or even
clustering the problem with clustering
is it requires at least one forward pass
of the entire data set
so the real innovation that uh matild
has presented in this paper is coming up
with an online clustering algorithm
mathilde and her co-authors have decided
to treat the clustering problem
as an optimal transport problem and
solve it using the sinkhole knob
algorithm so we'll go into some detail
in the call today about exactly how that
works
matilda and her co-authors also came up
with a new approach for doing data
augmentation so many of the papers
like simclear and p-i-r-l and moko and
so on
they already have things like color
distortion and random flipping
and gaussian blur and gray scale and
stuff like that but
these folks introduce this multi-scale
cropping
and they also for the first time have
multiple views of a single image
in this architecture they learn codes
for the image
and then they swap the code so they try
and predict the codes from another view
of the same image
and that's their approach for doing the
unsupervised or the self-supervised
learning task
so in their architecture multiple views
are generated
with crops and then augmented with
sequentially applied
traditional augmentations like color
distortion random flipping and gaussian
blur
the views are then passed for a cnn
resnet50 backbone
those representations then get passed
through a fully connected
network z those representations then get
passed through a fully connected network
so the representations are fed for a
linear layer c and then k
prototype vectors are projected from z
so this allows us to create these codes
we then compute these codes
using the sinkhorn algorithm then we
formulate this using the swapped
prediction problem
which is when the code of an image is
predicted from another view
of the same image so in summary this is
a new
clustering-based self-supervised
approach for
image representation learning the
results on this are just incredible
it improves the performance of
self-supervision by up to 4.2 percent on
imagenet with the standard resnet 50
backbone
and it improves the pre-training of
downstream tasks and this is the first
method to do so
without any fine-tuning whatsoever also
it's been shown to work really really
well in semi-supervised tasks
outstripping the performance of
supervised methods and it does rather
raise the question
why are these methods so good
self-supervision just seems to be an
absolute game changer
the representations that are learned
seem to generalize even better
than those learned in respect of a
supervised task and it seems to be a bit
of a mystery in general
why would representations from something
like imagenet generalized to a
completely different task in a different
domain
what's going on there will we ever
understand this one of the things that
yannick brought up
was gently challenging whether could it
be a function of imagenet on imagenet
the classes
are quite homogeneous and it's because
imagenet was derived from wordnet which
was a
lexical database of words which was
designed to group or to
distinguish the words based on their
linguistic context
imagenet just maps those classes to the
same words that were in the lexical
database
wordnet so is it possible that the
amazing results we're getting here with
the clustering
uh conception of self-supervised image
representation learning
is because of the way that the
information is partitioned and segmented
in imagenet or is it something that
would generalize to
other types of data set i also raised
the question as well
that there's a dichotomy between
experience and priors this is something
that francois charles said
and facebook is in the enviable position
that they have access to almost all of
the data on the internet
they have access to a an instagram data
set with a billion images in it
and they are pushing the boundary much
as open ai are pushing the boundary on
gpt3
because they have access to so much data
but there's an argument that we should
be focusing on priors rather than
infinite amounts of experience and image
augmentations but if we were focused on
image augmentations what kind of
augmentations would be better
than the kind that we've devised already
when does image augmentations finish and
when does
image synthesis start these are all
really interesting questions and we'll
put these to matild today
i really want to thank ayush and sayak
for facilitating this conversation today
they have put this incredible article
together they've recreated matilda's
experiments
and they've explained it in a
beautifully simple way
apparently it took them about two months
to do all of this because they basically
reproduced a lot of the work that
matilde did so i really recommend you
you go and check that article out
and those guys hang out in the slack
channel on the weights and biases um
slack so
definitely go and reach out to those
folks they've done a great job thank you
very much i hope you enjoy the show
today and we'll see you soon instead of
showing you a headshot of myself
i thought i'd do show you a bit of the
nice weather here in zurich
so the conversation you're about to hear
is with
ayush and matilda sayak and tim
and myself about self-supervised
learning learning features
for images and this i think is going to
be
more and more of a giant topic in the
future
as we just gather more and more data
labeling images is as hard as ever but
gathering images becomes easier and
easier
so techniques to extract features
without labels are going to be more and
more important
and i think the more progress we make
and images
the easier it gets to then carry over
that progress
to other types of data like
language audio whatever you want
so i hope you enjoy this conversation i
had a lot of fun i
actually learned many many things and
i think questioning authors and also
people who
try to re-implement the author's work
directly
is just something that's valuable beyond
what you can read in a paper
all right with that i'll let you go
bye-bye
okay well welcome back to the machine
learning street talk
youtube channel with me tin scarf and my
compadres for today so of course we have
yannick lightspeed culture
we also have ayush takuya and uh ayusha
is a machine learning consultant at the
weights and biases and the growth team
he's from uh kolkata in india
he's also the co-founder and chief
technical officer of the code foundation
which is an open source organization
focusing on developing cutting-edge
technological solutions
that are in high demand in the community
um he's got an amazing medium page and
he's written lots of articles
things like interpretability and and
debugging your networks with pytorch
uh we also have mr sayak paul
sayek is an absolute legend he's joining
us for the second time
um i introduced him in great detail last
time but he's an intel
software innovator um he's a google
developer expert
he's a deep learning associate at pi
image search he's a co-author of a book
hands-on deep learning um for the web
he's written loads of amazing articles
as well and he's all over social media
and today we have a very special guest
matilde carol she did her
postgraduate degree in applied
mathematics from eccol polytechnic
a masters in computer science from the
royal institute of technology
uh in stockholm specializing in machine
learning
she was a research intern at philips and
at the moment she's a research assistant
at facebook ai
and inria specializing in image
recognition
and she's working towards her phd now
matild has written an amazing paper
called
unsupervised learning of visual features
by contrasting cluster assignments
and i wonder if you could just explain
this paper to us like with five imagine
people have been
living in a cave and they don't know
anything about your paper uh give us the
elevator pitch
okay thanks tim thank you so much for
inviting me to
this show and to organizing this so it's
really my pleasure to
talk about my our recent contributions
suave
and also to talk about unsupervised
future learning in general
so the problem we've been taking in this
paper as well
is unsupervised feature learning so as
you may know a typical setting to solve
an image recognition task
has relied in the past few years in two
stages
so the first stage is the pre-training
of a large
of a cnn or the convolutional neural
network on a large-scale supervised data
set so typically
imagenet and then the second stage is to
use those representations to solve a
downstream task so for example
object detection on on a small data set
and so in unsupervised feature learning
or self-supervised
learning what we want to do is to
replace this first step
in this this first pre supervised
pre-training step by
unsupervised free training so it means
that we want to learn
representations without using any
annotations
so how do we do that how do we train
convolutional neural networks without
using any annotations
well what we can do is to leverage uh
something that we know is that uh one
image
uh has a semantic content and like
all distortions that we can take in this
image all crops
uh all yes small views that we can take
in this image
will have the same semantic content so
in this paper we propose to leverage
that and we propose a method called
swell
that simultaneously clusters the data
while
enforcing the consistency between the
clustering segments
produced for different versions
distortion and crops of the same image
so as we know that distortion of the
same image contain the same semantic
information it should be possible to
predict
the group assignment cluster assignment
of a distortion
from the feature of another distortion
of this image
so in our paper we try to pre-train
with suave so on data set without labels
and we saw that this free training
actually boosts the performance of
different downstream tasks and we are
competitive and sometimes
even better than the supervised
counterpart that
consists in pre-training the conflict on
a
supervised data set such as imagenet
fantastic
i wonder whether you could give us a
little bit more detail on the need for
clustering in particular because i'm
i'm just reading a tiny bit from your
paper now and you say that the
contrastive loss explicitly compares
pairs of image representations to push
away representations from different
images while pulling together
those from the same transformations or
views but you say that computing all of
the pairwise comparisons on a large data
set is not practical
and most implementations approximate the
loss by reducing the number of
comparisons to random subsets
or um what we're moving towards here is
using clustering but of course
clustering is intractable so
you need to do any forward pass on the
entire data set essentially and i
understand that one of the main
innovations in in your work is doing
um an online version of the clustering
but could you kind of contrast
where your approach sits in with other
methods that don't do clustering
okay so as you very well summarize
the contrastive method uh or doing like
instance discrimination so they
discriminate between each image
and so to do this uh you need to have
the representations for all images in
the data set so it's really
uh expensive and you cannot do it in
practice so as you said
most implementation they rely on the
approximation of this
loss and they take only a subset of
example
and so in our work we try to like
leverage clustering because
we
because for example if you have a
downstream task
on classification you hope that you will
need
to learn some signal from inter
images similarities you know that
in the data set there is some
similarities between images
and in the contrastive approaches you do
not directly
leverage that so that's why we wanted to
have a method
that that like cluster
different images uh together and that
discriminate between groups of images
absolutely i think it does one of the
things i'm thinking about is many of the
contrastive algorithms even like the
triplet loss for example
one of the problems is um it's very
difficult to train the algorithms and
it takes a long time for them to
converge and in some of those algorithms
there was the concept of a mining
strategy to
provide examples that help the algorithm
learn faster
but is this clustering approach an
alternative to that
uh yes i oh i think it's just
two different approaches so i think
there could be improvement
and there is room for improvement for
contrasted learning to try to
and have a hard negative sampling of
this kind of stuff so for now the
proposed approaches for in
self-supervised learning
at least have done only noise
contrastive estimation
where the negative samples
are sampled randomly but
yeah you could think of strategies to uh
to improve
this same thing of course and our
approach clustering uh here the idea is
that you want to
like summarize the information of
several instances with prototypes so
it's just
i think two different approaches
what do you what do you make of these
clusters i mean ultimately
you your only constraint is that the two
versions of the same image must land in
the same cluster
and so what do you where do you
think the required information because
so first of all could you
do you have you seen any regularities
with respect to the clusters like you
can look at the prototypes
maybe what do you what do you see in the
prototypes but also
where do you think where do you think
the network learns to cluster these
things
because the only thing it knows is which
two things are equal right
yes so there are two questions and the
first one is
did we like visualize the the clusters
that we get
so it's something that we can do so
i think of two ways to do it so first we
could like
look at the prototypes themselves uh
look how do they behave in the
future space how they are like
put in the feature space
and also the other way could be to look
at the different images which are
assigned to the same prototype
so we don't we didn't do it for the
suave
paper but we did it for our
previous contributions deep cluster and
deep
and deeper cluster which are like very
related to this work
and we found like the cluster that we
would obtain
were very like i mean not all of them
but we could
we could mine some semantically uh
similar
clusters so for example uh in in the
deeper cluster paper
uh we pre-trained uh this uh
method on the on the flickr data set
which is composed of
like a social media content
and we found that uh we could uh obtain
clusters
we which were like very correlated
by uh for example user ids or gps
coordinates
and uh like uh
like also correlated with a hashtag so
we could have a clusters of
containing like cats mainly
or elephants or this kind of stuff
yeah so we mattered
so for your information ayush and i did
try to visualize the clusters
uh learned uh by the prototype uh layer
and also we tried to
you know visualize the codes that get
you know mapped by the synchronous
algorithm
so what in our tiny implementation what
we did found is we couldn't you know
extract dense clusters from the
prototype
and also the code uh spit
by the synchronous algorithm so ayush
and i kind of
sat and we talked talked it out to
ourselves that
maybe because of the you know
contrastive nature
between the different codes and the
prototypes
they are you know approaching this from
the
you know classical clustering
visualization kind of approach that
might not be directly applicable
because we tried out you know different
visualization methods on the kind of
uh learned prototypical vector and also
the code but we couldn't find any dense
relationship
in between them but again as i mentioned
it's it might be solely because
of the contrastive nature uh between the
different views
of the you know of different images so
just wanted to
uh share our findings with you folks so
i hope that's useful yeah maybe uh tim
this would be a good time to also
mention that that um
that zayak and ayush have actually
written a pretty good article about this
paper
sayakan and i yes they've written this
incredible article
i think that there's almost as much
information in your article as there is
in the original paper
not only not only have they explained
the paper they've actually um
implemented it in uh in tensorflow and i
think there were a couple of issues
where they
they had to rewrite some functionality
because it was in
i think that the splits thing that the
chops was in pie torch but it wasn't in
tensorflow so so you folks managed to
get it working and and you've really got
some results and reproduced it
and this is actually super cool because
i think one of the problems we have
these days is it's quite difficult to
reproduce work that
that gets published and i know matthias
has been on hand to help you folks uh
write that article and to reproduce the
results so
yeah this is a a great story as far as
i'm concerned yeah so martin
had had been you know had been our
pillar of
support whenever we reached out to her
she like
responded with absolute greed i mean we
had this
very minor technical uh prose kind of
mistakes in our article
and she did help us correct that kind of
stuff we had some
you know issue we had some doubts in the
official implementation of swag which is
really well maintained
uh as at least what we think we had some
you know doubts and
she was very generous enough to clear
all those doubts for us so
that really helped and it took us almost
more than
more than 1.5 months to complete the
entire project so it was
kind of challenging for us i mean
starting from the multi-crop
augmentation policy
to implementing it and to then you know
realizing the entire algorithm and then
writing out the article it was
kind of what of our efforts because it's
amazing
and that's what at least we can say so
yeah
that's incredibly inspiring i mean from
my point of view i know yannick
shares my philosophy on this um it's an
incredible time to be alive
we have such uh we have amazing online
communities now
and we have common ways of working and
exactly as you're demonstrating you're a
couple of guys that have got a passion
for the subject and you've just put your
heads together
you're looking at some of the cutting
edge research from fair and
you've produced this work and you've
actually you know you you've
reproduced it and made it work so yeah
well well done guys
thank you um i would i would be i would
be very interested to go more into this
type of
of clustering that you're doing because
i've had a look at a couple of papers
that kind of do
clustering in you know feature space
latent space
uh making the loss with respect to that
so first of all there's something in
your paper
that's called the the synchron knob
algorithm
which i think is not super well known so
i would you would you any of you like to
give us kind of an intuition of what
this algorithm is doing and how it's
actually used
in in your in in suave i was reading
through the article from uh from sayaka
naya's just now
and and they've said that you treat the
assignment as the optimal transport
problem and solve it using the sinkhorn
knob algorithm
and i went online because i hadn't heard
about this and um and of course you've
created an online version of this so you
run the algorithm for every single batch
and of course it's it's quite
complicated because you have different
views and the views might have different
resolutions and so on
i went to the wikipedia page and it said
in mathematics and economics
transportation theory or transport
theory is a name given to the study of
optimal transportation and allocation of
resources and it was formalized by the
french mathematician
um gaspard mongen in 1781 so
i'm fascinated to know how you've used
this so
basically what we want to do is that we
want to assign
the features so the image
representations
to prototypes to clusters and what you
can do is simply
you take the dot products of the
features and the prototypes
and you take the max of the dot product
so you want
for each like for each feature
representation to be assigned
to the prototypes that is more similar
to it
so the thing is if you do that without
any constraint
the network is going to cheat and to
assign all the features to one prototype
and then it's going to be super easy to
predict
the prototype all of this is that we
want to assign features to prototypes
without without collapsing so we want to
prevent collapsing
so for this we enforce a constraint and
the constraints are that
all prototypes should be equally
representative
so for example if you have a batch of
size
b and k prototypes you want
that each prototype has
like k over b
examples assigned to it
so the our problem is an assignment
problem so we want to assign features to
prototypes
and we have constraints of eq of
equi partition and so if you write
this problem down then you end up with a
like a a problem that has been
already studied in math and it's
actually uh
an instance of a optimal transport
problem
and there is an algorithm which is
called synchron knob
that solves this problem so we simply
plugged the algorithm in our method
in order to solve this assignment
problem but it's really like
big names like optimal transport and
synchron
synchronic knob but the problem is
really easy just
assigning cluster features to clusters
with constraints you say one of the
differences of your work to other works
is you keep
the soft cluster assignments around
instead of
of hard of heart clustering how does
that play into into your algorithm
yes so at the beginning we were using uh
hard dots in man so the solution of the
single knob algorithm is an ascendant
matrix
and it's uh it's like it's soft
so it's a sign it's soft so it's
assigned
one feature to like uh it outputs a
probability of
like belonging to each of the prototype
and we were doing like a rounding uh
on this uh probably probability matrix
and we were taking like
the prototype with the highest
probability
so this is all the ceiling and
we were doing this following a previous
work and also because it
it's it's like looks more natural
at least to my mind to have like one
prototype
assign one feature assigned to one
but actually we found that when we were
doing this the loss was going very
quickly down as we show in the paper i
think
and uh we found that uh like it was
uh like uh the optimization
for the prototypes were going we're
going too fast
and uh that were that was resulting in a
lower performance on the doorstream task
so we found that uh using the software
segment was a way to slowly down the
optimization and to prevent
the prototypes to like optimize too fast
and and
not be very relevant uh
i mean that's our inter interpretation
but
once again it's very empirical just we
tried
both and we took the one that was
working the best
i wonder if you could give us a little
bit of intuition on this um
sync horns theorem so i went to the
wikipedia page and it said imagine you
have a matrix a
which is an n by n matrix with strictly
positive elements
then there exists two diagonal matrices
d1 and d2
with strictly positive elements such
that if you multiply d1 by your matrix
times d2
it is doubly stochastic now that means
that the rows and the columns sum to one
and apparently a simple iterative method
to approach the matrix you know just to
alternatively rescale all the rows and
columns of a
to sum to one is is the way that you
compute that is is that is that what it
is
yes yes okay yeah i also wanted to ask
regarding keeping the code assignment
part to their soft variant only
is it is it might be because we are
kind of operating on a mini batch and we
do not have a holistic overview
of the data set or the domain that we
are operating on
so maybe taking the hard hard enough
clusters won't be
that much informative for the downstream
tasks and
because the number of samples in a
particular mini batch is kind of small
so to get the you know to get the most
information out of them keeping the
code assignments to only their soft
variant
would be more helpful so could this be
another explanation to it
yes definitely because as we're doing
the
the assignment like online only at the
batch level it
may not be very precise especially at
the beginning
so if you do like the rounding and you
take the hard ascendant you're doing
like something very brutal in the
optimization
and you're doing you're going to like
completely
lose your information and
i mean it works but we see that uh you
you lose some performance so yeah that's
right definitely
and it's it's true that uh when we were
doing the
like offline version of it so which is
very similar to
the work of assanito we did experimented
so we have the cluster cement uh so we
solved the synchron problem on the
entire data set
we found that it was not making so much
of a difference to use a soft assignment
versus
a hard assignment so it was especially
for the batch
the batch version of it i i i was
wondering about
um maybe the intuition behind behind
this clustering it seems to me
it is a natural approach to do
clustering however clustering it seems
there's so much information in images
and we as we as humans we look at an
image and we recognize
okay i can look at this image as you
know there's
an animal on it but i can look at this
image as
you know in terms of oh this is you know
these are very
i don't know bright colors and this
other picture is maybe more
pastel this picture was shot in fall
this picture was shot in spring this
picture
you know i can look at it in all kinds
of different ways and i'm thinking
clustering seems to be the wrong
approach just
you know just i i see it works better
but just from
a principal point of view because with
clustering
i can i have to make these clusters
right i can say here is a group of
images and they share something
and in in the way they share something
with each other they
don't share that thing without
everything else and then
if i put something in a different
cluster right that thing is in there and
and
it's different from anything else so i'm
wondering
how much of this um is maybe
maybe you know with these image data
sets a lot of them are classification
or classification like data sets like
object detection and so on where
there is a clear objective to the way
the data set is created
like imagenet there's the clear
objective is to build
a classifier for single things so the
image is going to be single things and
there's a clear way to group them and
i'm wondering
how much of the the usefulness of
clustering in these pre-training
approaches
is due to the fact that the and i'm i'm
i'm guessing none of
uh we might be speculating here
but how how much do you think the nature
of the data sets themselves
is playing into your favor here in the
clustering and
and could could clustering also work in
something like
you know nlp where it's much more
vague if i just give a book i think
yannick i think you're saying that
your hypothesis is the clusters are not
homogeneous
so by making a one cluster you're
disadvantaging yourself
in another respect because there might
be some semantic information which is
captured in that cluster
but some other semantic information
which is split in that cluster
exactly and then i'm i'm wondering is
because these image data sets are made
basically to to be clustered right
how much is that played out here and how
much how much of the clustering
objective is really actually because
it's a good objective
uh independent of this uh according to a
semantic
uh criteria but maybe you're going to
cluster your data
according to the pixel on the left or
according to colors
or what you say according to the uh the
the seasons like four springs they are
like uh
crucial uh to make the to make this
method uh work
so as i was saying as we take like uh
we want like all distortions and crops
uh
of the same image to be like mapped in
the same cluster
so it's like ensures that the cluster is
not going
to be about the pixel on the left for
example because
this pixel on the left will not be
consent constant
across the different crops and the
distortion color distortion
and so on of this same of
these different cluster members also
like it's true that we are using uh like
uh
imagine we are pre-training on imagenet
without labels and it's kind of
cheating because uh like imagenet is by
by designed a cluster that i said that
has been designed for
like uh image classification
and so we wanted to like in our previous
paper
and also in this paper uh we wanted and
we found that it was very important to
evaluate our method
on like what we called incorporated data
set
which which are just like random images
taken from like a social
website so for the previous paper we we
took images
and so these images were completely uh
like and created and you imagine
you imagine that if you take like one
billion images from instagram you're not
going to end up with a nicely
clustered data set such as imagenet
you're going to have like tons of images
of baseball and cats and very few images
of
i don't know elephant anyway so
we found that it was super important to
evaluate in this setting
and we found that we had like
improvements over the previous
state of the art on this on this
benchmarks too
and we also found that we lose
i mean as expected that we lose
performance
when we pre-train uh on this data set
instead of
imagenet which is like a highly curated
even if you remove
the labels like in our method clustering
is a
effective because it works together with
a data transformation
and i think this kind of approaches
could work also for
nlp if you have like if you manage to
to cr to have like a strong data
augmentation
uh like designed for nlp like for
example with
i don't know synonyms or like
conjugation of this kind of stuff what
symbol
what um what data augmentations would
work in nlp
it maybe it's just my intuition but it
seems in computer vision it's easier to
come up with augmentations and of course
um i'd love to know more about how you
came up with your multi-crop strategy
but
just to make a couple of assertions um
to to carry on what yannick was saying
imagenet was derived from word net which
was a kind of tax anonymous
taxonomical lexical database of words
so it it does stand to reason that the
clusters are quite homogeneous they're
not intersecting
and i'm making the assumption as well
that in your algorithm the cluster
assignments are one to one
so every single view will have one
cluster and that also presupposes that
the clusters
can't be intersecting each other and i
wonder as well whether
would you accept that not using
clustering using the
um the contrastive approach would work
better if you had all of the compute in
the world
it it's that the main reason to do this
is from a computational perspective
just to a bit correct what you said
uh like one feature is assigned to uh
like
different prototypes because we are
doing soft assignments so it's not
assigned to like
one cluster so it can leverage the
intersection
in the in the in the clusters uh
and also like if we had infinite
compute i don't know what would happen i
mean deep learning
is a very empirical science and i think
we should just
try and see what happens i don't know
maybe
maybe that would be purely instant
discriminative
method that would that would work best
there
i don't know i would just uh
like to try and see have you tried
playing around a bit with the number of
clusters that you learn
um especially i'm interested what
happens if you
massively over cluster like if you
massively
have way more clusters than your data
set have not has natural
classes what what happens in that case
because i would
i would guess because the clusters you
even force them to be
sort of homogeneous uh to be equally
represented and so on
and i'm if i if my data set has two
classes naturally but i
make three clusters what happens
okay so in our paper we made an ablation
where we
varied the number of clusters and
overall what we found is that as long as
the
number of clusters is enough
then you get like a similar performance
so there is like a
inverse u shape when with an optimal
around the 10 10k cluster for imagenet
um but like if you go
up to like 100k clusters which is like
100 times more than the real number of
classes in the data set then you have
almost
the same performance but on the other
hand if you don't have
enough clusters then you lose
some performance much more performance
yeah
so yeah my takeaway would be like as
long as it's enough
it's good this kind of similar study was
also done in the self leveling paper by
asano at all
in their paper as well the number of
clusters
was three thousand exactly three
thousand and which is the number
uh that is used in the swept paper as
well and they also in their paper they
did a kind of
ablation study uh as to they scaled
their
you know number of clusters from
thousand to ten ten thousand and they
fi they found a sweet spot in when they
set the number to three thousand
so they also made some assumptions like
uh you could definitely incorporate some
kind of domain knowledge
to try to decide on the number of
clusters and you
uh or else you could just you know find
it out empirically
so these are the two assertions that
were made in the
uh self-leveling paper but
for example also uh when we trained on
one billion
uh instagram data we also
use the three key so you you would think
that
it's really not enough because
like you don't have only 3000 concepts
in
one billion images from instagram
and i would assume that we would have
gained
by increasing the number of clusters but
really what we wanted to show in this
experiment is that we can try
we can take like exactly the same
algorithm with
the same hyper parameters and see if it
works out of the box or on a completely
different
and trading data set so maybe on
instagram we are like
in with the number of clusters then we
will have better results
i mean i'm speculating here i was going
to move the conversation onto the
multi-crop
strategy because it says on on the the
intro
that you observe a consistent
improvement of between
two percent and four percent on imagenet
with this strategy on
several self-supervised methods so
adjust the multi-crop alone
is giving us a significant improvement
and
i think as sayak made the assertion in
his article that there might be some
um scale in variance there as well
although i'm not sure that's
completely the case because i think
typically if you only do a couple of
scales but
what's your intuition behind that how
did you come up with it
uh so at first
what i was doing was to reproduce uh
peone paper
by uh ishan and lawrence van der latten
and so i i was i was very
uh puzzled by uh by this uh pearl paper
and i
couldn't really get the intuition why uh
like having this jigsaw
jigsaw branch would improve the results
so i digged a bit uh
more into that and that's how i had the
idea of
like i i had the intuition that it was
more about like
the data augmentation that was used than
uh this jigsaw objective and so i tried
to like uh
rip off the uh pure method
of like and to to take
only the data augmentation of it and
i saw that that it was uh that it was
working uh
it was working well and then
yeah that's how that's how i i
i designed it you
are applying a sequence of augmentations
uh
sequence of augmentations for per view
in the multi-crop augmentation so like
was does
was a sequence of augmentations
something that you found empirically
which is working well or was it
something that you just came up with and
also the
sequence of augmentation that we used
was
is exactly the one from the sincere
paper
so in their paper the authors made like
very extensive
ablation of data augmentations like they
tried
many stuff and they picked the one which
was working the best so we just
took this this augmentation schemes and
we
didn't try to improve up upon it
so yeah in the in the swap paper we use
the
many improvements brought by the sincere
paper and i was very
grateful and about this
this paper it helped us a lot
yeah in fact when you use multi-crop
augmentation in the simpler work it
actually enhances
what sinclair has achieved already it
boosts the performance if i'm not wrong
by at least two percent
which is crazy if you just swap out the
sim clear augmentation with the
multi-crop augmentation propulsion swept
it achieves a performance boost of at
least two percent
and it's consistent across moco v2 uh if
you apply it on
probably on deep cluster there's also a
significant improvement
so there's this table in the swap paper
where just incorporating you know
multi-crop augmentation policy
you just get tremendous performance
boosts so
yes and i hope like researchers will try
on their own method because i i know
we tried it on different methods and
they it
it looked consistent so i hope uh
people will we'll try it we'll try it
our favorite friend francois chalet he
has a conception of intelligence as
being
a relationship between priors and
experience
so experience i guess would be the kind
of data augmentations we're talking
about lots and lots of ways to produce
more data
by creating some kind of semantically
equivalent
mutation or perturbation chalet would
argue maybe that we should be
more focused on creating useful
inductive priors so we don't need to
have so much data
because if you look at a cnn visualizer
there is uh that chris ola from distill
he's got this wonderful paper on feature
visualization and
um if you uh if you look at one of the
nodes in a typical imagenet classifier
it looks like a bicycle wheel but it's a
bit distorted
and clearly it's learned that
statistically all of the patterns and
all of the images it's seen of bicycle
wheels corresponds to this
um kind of funny bicycle wheel and
that's what it's learned
and i suppose it just seems a bit silly
to me do you think we should be going
down this road of the blank slate the
tava rossa and as much data as possible
or
do you think we should be going back to
the drawing board and creating better
inductive priors
i mean i don't really know and that's a
difficult question i think uh
the best would be to have efforts in uh
in both direction
to be sure that
we will reach our goal i would say i'm
more in the
like more data and scaling models a team
uh because because maybe because uh i'm
a
like in a gaffer at facebook where
i i can do this kind of stuff so i
i i kind of feel that i have to
leverage the compute that i have and
like i have the chance to
to be able to train models on like a
billion
images which is if you think about it
quite crazy
so yeah
i mean i mean in the scaling
and more data team but it doesn't mean
that i think the
the other team should not
like is not worth pursuing as well
i forgot to say on the introduction
we're incredibly jealous that you that
you get to work
at fair because the the resources that
you have access to
to push the envelope now that you've
said that out loud it's no surprise to
me whatsoever that this is the direction
you've taken because that
there's so much low hanging fruit and
you have these uh resources available
sure like it's i mean it's something
that i really
enjoy to to have this much uh
like compute power and and this much uh
data and it's
yeah you know it's it's very crazy to be
able to train on
like 1 billion 2 billion
10 billions images from from instagram
for example
and also to have like two so we
pre-train our model on the internal
data and then we can try to have some
impact on that
on like downstream tasks which are
useful for for facebook
like uh to prevent harmful content or to
prevent copy detection and all of this
i mean i'm not like doing this kind of
stuff because i'm in the in the research
team but i i feel it's kind of
empowering to
know that the work that i'm developing
can like very easily
be plugged in such as
could you take us a bit through the just
through the process of how this works at
facebook maybe at the example of this
project
from from the point like where
where you either heard of it or came up
yourself
to where you're working on it
to what kind of problems there are and
so on how
how free are you in doing this how does
this in general
or maybe at this project work for you
yes in general i i i'm not the best
trainer but
yes i can tell for my project so i've
been working on
like unsupervised future learning like
self-supervised learning
for like two years and a half
now almost three years and at the
beginning it wasn't that
a hot topic and it was especially not
applied on facebook data so it was
really
i mean not that interesting to facebook
yet
and uh like uh there was no problem for
me to
keep uh like doing stuff in that
direction and i would not have a
like uh pressure on the facebook side to
to have a big results and so on so
that is to say that i feel in
in fair we can have like a
research projects because we found them
interesting and not because they are
interesting for the companies
and there are many examples of of people
working at fair who are doing like i
don't know theoretical stuff or
stuff that don't have that are not
useful for
for facebook at least not yet so anyway
uh so yeah for
two years and three and two years and a
half i've been working on this
and now recently it has
been like we we had we have had a
better results thanks to like the
improvements of the
previous work of the literature and also
of our contribution
so of course it's uh it's interesting
for facebook to
be able to leverage all the unlabeled
content and that is uh uploaded on the
on their websites and so that's why we
are now like in contact
with the like production teams uh
to try to you know collaborate and uh
and have this uh used in production as
well it sounds pretty cool so so in
essence
your life was easier when no one cared
yes
cool
that's interesting since we were talking
about image augmentation
so what's so how do you see the progress
of image augmentation for our supervised
regime because there's a lot of
augmentation techniques that's been
developed for
supervisors yes and i think my belief is
that
i mean something that would be
definitely interesting to do and that is
a
low-hanging fruit is to do like what has
been done for us
for supervised that augmentation but to
do it for unsupervised
that augmentation as we know that it's
like what makes everything works
work so yeah you could think about
like reinforcement learning strategies
to such as a round around the
augment like data augmentation strategy
but dedicated to unsupervised learning i
think that's
definitely a promising uh direction that
to the best of my knowledge hasn't been
much explored yet as an extension of
that question i wonder what you think
about the dichotomy between
image augmentation and image generation
because one of the problems with neural
networks is they don't reason
so if you put in a complex uh you know
like a
a premise and a hypothesis into a
natural language
processing model or even some textual
entailment it's very easy to trip it up
because it's not reasoning
and similarly computer vision models
aren't reasoning either they're not
spatially reasoning
so i wonder one way to fix that if you
do if you do assume that neural networks
are just a big hash table and they need
to
learn every possible combination of
semantic information
maybe the best way to achieve that would
be to write some kind of a physical
simulation and to
generate loads and loads of data so do
you see a potential future for that
yes i definitely agree with you and
yeah i mean that's not the kind of
approaches which are
like uh reaching the state of the art
right now but i think they are like
promising and they're promising and they
should be working that direction
but maybe they could meet in the middle
do you think that a new form of
data augmentation could be transforming
an image into some kind of a 3d scene
and inside that scene we can do
reasoning we can say well these things
aren't allowed to occupy the same space
and
when i throw this thing at this thing
that happens and would that allow us to
create more sophisticated data
augmentation
yeah actually i think that's uh like a
very good research direction like
uh at some point i was i was trying to
i was doing something i was like uh
taking an agent in the virtual
environment so for example in a gibson
data set or this kind of stuff
and i would like move around the agent
and take screenshots
of what the engine sees and use that as
that augmentation so for example
you have your laptop in front of you and
you would like move the agent
the agent around the laptop to have like
a 3d
dot augmentation of it and i would train
the cnn with like a contrastive love
with these data augmentations so it was
super disappointing to see that it was
not
working better than the random resize
crop
and so we just like dropped uh that
direction to do something else but
yeah that's definitely something we
thought about and i think
this uh yeah this direction is not
completely
closed i hope yeah i think you meant to
say not working yet
yeah so um
with respect to things not working
um because i'm always interested in in
the process of kind of how
research is done because we're often
talking about you know the end result
the end project and this is is shiny and
all
but exactly right
but for most projects out of experience
you you are at a point when things don't
don't work and so can you maybe in this
project you know maybe it was all smooth
but
maybe you had yeah so what kind of
experiences had you had where you
thought oh this isn't working and that
at that point what did you do like what
was what was the method to overcome
like a hurdle in this project
so yes i definitely agree with you and
we had like many uh pain points
i can say and like i cannot talk about
all of this
so at the beginning
so we read this sincerely paper and
we found that there were many
improvements such as the
learning rate schedule the strong data
augmentation the non-linear
projection head which were actually like
very good
but orthogonal to the contrastive
objective so our
this is how the project started is that
we wanted to
plug the sim clr training improvements
into
deep cluster which is the work that we
published two years ago
and so it was working but
it's it was not uh working like as we
wished
uh it would work and uh so that was one
i mean the first uh like uh problem that
we had
and the thing is in deep clusters so you
cluster the
the data and then you train uh the
network to predict the
pseudo labels that you get with cluster
assignments and the thing is
you do a new clustering at each epoch
and so the final classification layer
it has to be reset at each epoch because
your clusters they do not map
between an epoch to another so it means
that
the the loss is very jumpy
like it's at the beginning of each epoch
you have like one layer which is a
initialized from scratch so it makes the
whole training completely unstable
intuitively this is the
last classification layer it learns
prototypes for each
for each cluster so we thought uh how
can we replace that
so the thing is in k-mean clustering you
get centroids and
trades there are prototypes for the for
the different crystals
so basically what you're trying to do
with this final classification
layer is to learn the sound rate so what
we thought is that can we just replace
this classification layer with the
centroids
directly and compare the features to the
prototypes that we got with clustering
and when we did that that that was
working like super well
and the the the training would improve i
mean the stability
would improve dramatically because you
would not have this
these bumps at each epoch
and also was increasing so yeah that's
that's uh the first like problem that we
had and we had to
sit around the table and uh you know
figure out a solution to
to improve the stability of training so
this is how you came up with the
learnable
prototype kind of thing so probably this
lead you to using a linear layer to
learn all the prototype and keep that as
a bank which would evolve during the
training
so i like the moody that's that's what
that was for
deep cluster so what we call deep
cluster v2 and then the second problem
that we had
is that so deep cluster v2 was working
very well but
it was not online it was a
like it was a method that would require
several
passes on the data set to update the
prototypes
which were on the clusters in the
cluster centroids
and the cluster assignment so now the
then the problem was to like
have the same learning signal as in deep
cluster v2
but uh do it like at the batch level and
for this we
like took inspiration from uh sincerely
where
they have like the 2d distorted version
of the
same image within the same batch and so
we
we thought oh we can do this for
clustering actually we can like have the
two distorted version in the same batch
have a cluster assignment for one
and then predict with the other one and
that's how we
we thought about it yeah you are
first taking the embedding from the rest
of 50 then projecting it using the
projection layer and then passing it
through the prototype
so like have it right passing the
embedding directly to the prototype
and then trying to do the online
clustering and we did not
try that we we only experimented with
the
like projection head the and we didn't
try
the linear projection head actually we
only tried the non-linear
one introduced by uh sincerella okay but
that's something that can easily be
implemented i think
but we did not write
might be a quick time to talk about your
results
so um you say in in your paper that's uh
combining the
the technical contributions into a
single model so you know your
your um multi-crop and the online
clustering
you can improve the performance of sales
supervisors by about
plus 4.2 percent on imagenet with a
standard resnet
and you can also outperform supervised
imagenet pre-training on multiple
downstream tasks and it's the first
method to do so without fine-tuning the
features
and also um elsewhere in the paper you
talk about semi-supervised results as
well so just given
um a fraction of the actual labels you
can also
perform significantly better so um i
just wondered what what was your
thoughts on on the general results that
you presented
just in the paper on the uh on the
imagenet classification benchmark where
you like uh
portraying the trunk uh on your
self-supervised loss
and then you freeze uh this these
weights and you only train
uh inner layer on top of the
representations
uh so i think uh this uh like this
benchmark is very widely used and very
useful to compare like a kind of apple
to apple the different methods
but if you think about it it's not like
a useful
uh benchmark like if you do have all the
labels for imagenet why not like just
training on all the levels directly
so i think this benchmark is a bit
artificial and is here to
it's very useful because it allows to
compare the different methods
but it does not in my opinion reflect
a real world scenario
so i think what is more important and
that people have been doing and
that we have been doing in this paper is
to show results where you have a
downstream task
that you what is usually performed to
solve
an image recognition task is that you do
this pre-training
and then you use this pre-trained
backbone to solve to improve
boost the performance on the downstream
task and
like typically for your downswing test
you have a small data set and if you
train from scratch
on this data set then you will have bad
performance because
like you would just overfit on your data
so yeah i think it's it's kind of
important to show results
for like a different uh kind of
downstream tasks for like for object
detection with several
uh frameworks or also instance retrieval
like met or
many like image recognition tasks you
can think about like a semantic
segmentation
that we did not do but i think that
would be interesting as well
uh like tracking uh in videos
like basically all tasks where
like uh people use an imaginative
backbone or a pre-trained cnn
the downstream tasks are important and
that people should
evaluate on them let's consider
a recipe for more practical use cases
where you don't have huge chunks of
you know label data set to you know do
the actual linear evaluation that's kind
of
the benchmark of this self-supervised
visual representation
frameworks that we get to see these days
so let's let's consider the scenario
where
you have somehow you know get where you
have somehow gathered
a huge chunk of unlabeled data corpus
and you have trained
trained trained a feature backbone model
using the swap framework
so i i think it might be prudent enough
for the companies to you know
only invest in probably putting together
one percent five percent or i don't know
ten percent label data set
and only use use use that for the
downstream fine tuning task
i think that also works so the recipe
would be to gather
huge chunks of unlabeled data corpus
trained a self-supervised learning model
to its you know
to its ingenuity and then
put together some effort to gather
together probably
five percent of ten percent label data
set and then
use the you know uh self-supervised
pre-training
for the downstream fine tuning test so
that might be immensely helpful
for more practical use cases and that's
why probably we get to see
you know one person fine-tuning results
ten percent fine-tuning results and so
on
and which i which i think are are
amazing to see i mean
we are only training on ten percent
fine-tuning on ten percent we
built it and still we are able to push
the state of that so i think that's
pretty exciting
yes i agree i have the same question
that i had before
to matild but to uh ayush and sayak
um you reading first of all reading
through the paper but then actually
going your way to re-implement
this and uh trying to do so in a way
because you knew
you were you would want to also share
out the code and all
uh usually if i as a researcher
re-implement something i just
make it work however right but but
could you could you maybe describe also
what kind of roadblocks you
you hit into when you were trying to do
this um
you alluded a bit at the beginning but
just how
where were you stuck and how did you
overcome that when we were
reading the paper uh so it took at least
maybe a two or three days to actually
grab all the novel bits
that people have and actually there are
multiple novel bits
it's not just usually a paper have one
novel bits and it just have three or
four
like off the back uh so yeah we had
multiple discussions
and about re-implementing it was mostly
uh
it was mostly so that we have a better
understanding of the paper
because once we see the code uh the
mathematical formulas do make
more sense i mean that's how we i
approach
uh studying a paper and yeah so
we know that we will be open sourcing
our code and everything so the idea was
to
have a like a very clean and readable
modular code so that anyone who
reads this paper have less friction
understanding the paper
and one and few bottlenecks if i have to
describe here is that
we we got stuck with uh the speed of our
multi crop
augmentation implementation where
uh where we got very released out to
google for help and we were mentioning
about the projection right so
uh for the imagenet there are 3000
prototypes
so since we were implementing our flower
dataset we initially started with 3000
product types but
after uh like say few experiments we
noticed that it's not gonna work so we
reduced that to 15 or 20 projections
yeah so there's this another bottleneck
where you do not have a very clean
implementation of random resize crop in
tensorflow
but you get that right off the bat in
python
right and it does have a
tensorflow slim probably has an
implementation but
if you were to operate in in eager mode
in tensorflow
that might not work because the
tensorflow slim implementation that i
just mentioned it
typically works in sessions you know and
we wanted to get rid of
tensorflow sessions uh anyway so we kind
of you know tried to
have a one-on-one replica of the
multi-crop augmentation
policy that proposed in swept and we
were kind of
uh somewhat satisfied with our
implementation then we
kind of studied the original swap
implementation like for
two or three days to actually understand
how
the multi-views are you know being
gathered and how the forward pass is
done
and that particular part i would
encourage all of our leader
viewers to take a look at that how
clever
is that particular part of code where
you are gathering together
different resolution views and then you
are you know
concatenating them in a very systematic
way and then finally you are
making a forward pass so that part was
one of the most struggling bits for us
then yeah then
after we had the data generators
finally you know up and running when we
were able to finally visualize
what what would come out of the
multi-crop augmentation policy then
the things you know became very lenient
we
kind of studied what synchronous policy
is what's an optimal transport problem
then we you know decided to go back
again to take a look at the original
implementation
the training loop and then we had
multiple discussions
peer codings and stuff like that and
then finally we were able to kick start
uh the training process so just to you
know just to
be very clear we do leave out
some bits of the paper intentionally
because
our goal uh is to you know
give our readers all the major bits
that's proposed in the paper for example
we do not incorporate queues because we
are operating on
on a batch size of 64 typically so
it did not make sense for us to
incorporate queues and stuff like that
also
the paper uses a combination of linear
warm-up
and cosine learning rate decay in terms
of the learning radical schedule for
for first epoch i guess it uses warm up
linear warm up and then it uses cosine
learning rate decay
again a very classic self supervised
learning
you know recipe that we get to see in
all the recent papers
but we you know we decided to go with
the simple cosine decay
policy and stuff like that so there is
there are these
little nitty gritties that we kind of
intentionally defer
we decided to intentionally differ but
yeah our goal was to you know
get through the papers novel bits and we
were absolutely awestruck
when we were finally able to you know
get through
at least to a brief understanding of the
entire people so
that's that has been the process so far
yeah
and i i agree that the like the uh
optimization uh specific uh parts
such as like the course and the learning
right schedule
they are like orthogonal to the swap
method or to any method and that
you should you should just uh take the
schedule that is adapted to your data
set and if
yes if you have a like i don't know
your training regime but it's it's not
like
necessary to do a like warm up and
consign learning right you know in your
schedule
in your training regime
and also you
uh i think it might it might be worth it
to
use it if you are training at uh small
batches i mean we introduced it
uh when when we were training at small
batches because as you're doing like the
assignments uh within the batch if you
don't have enough like features in your
batch
then your like your approximation is
going to be bad because
what you do is that you approximate the
like whole
data set assignment but within the batch
and if your batch is too small then it
does not work
very well so what we do is we simply
take the features from the previous
batches to like
solve the assignment problem on the
bigger set
of images and in your case like
it might bring a boost
i guess yeah we did actually uh tried
incorporating q in a you know in a
later experiment but just so that we all
know flowers dataset
only has probably 3500 examples
so you know even given the complexity
of the framework with respect to the
dataset that we were trying
incorporating you you are using uh
20 prototypes you said right like
yeah we we experimented with from
10 uh to 20. so we kind of find we can
kind of found the speed spot in 15.
so i think the queue is important when
like the number of prototypes is
big uh compared to the uh
to your batch size because what you do
is that you assign
the number the batch size uh features to
like
k prototypes and if you i mean it's not
very uh i mean if the number of
prototypes is too small
it's a bit uh a weird problem to assign
like
many many uh um
[Music]
i mean the other way around to to assign
like very few
uh examples to many many prototypes
it's a bit weird
is there an analogy here because you
know we've we've said the same
thing initially about the contrastive
objective is that in the contrastive
objective
it's really sad that we can't use the
whole data set to
approximate whatever your negative
samples right
um to to normalize your distribution in
the clustering
it's really sad that we don't have the
entire data set to compute the
clustering loss right
so uh what what what do you think is the
is kind of the fundamental or is is the
difference that makes the clustering
apparently work better when you have a
stochastic approach
i mean yes for both of them you have to
do something
because you cannot have the whole data
set and as you want to work
like online like you have to do
something at the batch level or
something with the previous computation
like in moco or with our queue mechanism
so yeah i think what uh i don't know
like maybe what might be making uh
like the clustering based approaches uh
like having slightly better performance
would be that
with this clustering you can like kind
of summarize
uh different images together with the
prototypes and like
you uh like kind of
indirectly you compare to uh
to something that is more representative
of the of the dataset
yeah i i i love yannick's line
of reasoning here i think it's related
to what he was talking about earlier and
i i would like to extend the line of
reasoning as well
because it's difficult to know whether
it's because of the clustering or
whether the results are somehow related
to
the way that the problem is formulated
and the semantics and the data
but i want to move a little bit towards
self-supervised
learning in general now clearly you work
for facebook and the chief scientist
there is
yan the and yanderkoon has this
vision about uh self-supervised learning
and we've got some of his slides from
iclr he says you know you can predict
the future from the past
you can predict the invisible from the
visible you can predict occluded mast or
corrupted
parts from available parts or you can
pretend there is an input that you don't
know about
and i'd like to know philosophically why
is unsupervised better than supervised
because neural networks what they do is
they learn
they're kind of like a clever
compression lookup algorithm and
i wha what influences it because you
said oh i can train on all of the data
on instagram
but is that a better thing or a worse
thing is that a trade-off because you've
got so many concepts now
um is that at the cost of something else
um
but because you also asserted that the
most important thing is the downstream
task that comes later
and for nlp that seems quite intuitive
because learning how to
speak language coherently seems to be
useful
for downstream tasks but in vision
learning
and some representations from imagenet
isn't necessarily going to be useful on
a downstream task
and you were talking about the
benchmarks but there's a tyranny of
benchmarks right so
yeah first of all it's not really a
question of is
unsupervised learning better than
supervised learning it's more like a
practical
and pragmatical uh pragmatic
consideration it's like in many
applications you just
do not have access to levels so like
what can you do like you don't have the
choice between supervised and supervised
learning you just have to go for
unsupervised learning because it's all
that you do it's all that you
have there so for example in like
domains such as medical images
it's the case annotations are super
expensive to get
also in like uh satellite images you
like them you can think of many
applications where annotations are just
difficult or impossible to get so that's
why like
unsupervised learning is so important
yes
so that's for the practical aspect of it
also
you mentioned the the downstream test so
it's true that
that on some benchmarks it's not
necessarily
like uh i mean if your downstream task
has
enough data like for example if you do
object detection
on the coco data set which is already
like quite big
you do not necessarily need uh to do
free training because uh
like your uh don't
swing that asset is uh big enough but
but on the end if you're you're
downstream task
you have i don't know like you see only
like a few thousand images if you're
trying directly
on these images you're going to overfit
like strongly
and you in this case in this scenario
you benefit from having uh learned like
general purpose
representations before
so yeah so for for example like
in medical images you would hope to have
this
like significant
data set which is not nebulous because
it's expensive and then you would like
to
learn uh representations which are like
specialized
to this domain and then you hope that
all the
data streams
on the military and that this uh
medical images specialized features will
help you solve
a downstream task on this domain there
are many
algorithm in medical images who are you
which are using like image net
pre-training and this is kind of crazy
if you think about it like
the imaginative images they have no
absolutely nothing to do about uh so
could you could you give us some
some intuition on that because similarly
your algorithm uh it works better than
supervised algorithms without any
fine-tuning
so why because you were talking about
overfitting and maybe learning some more
general representations
it seems crazy to me that you can train
on a completely different domain
and it's learning things which seem to
transfer to other domains and other
tasks and i think you and i both know
that it's
it's learning something superficial so
just just why do you think that it's
learning something which is even better
than the supervised representations
yes i like i was super uh surprised
uh to see that we could have like a
better performance with the unsupervised
algorithm compared to the supervised one
like when i was starting
uh working on like self-supervised
learning like uh
two years ago two years ago i would not
think that we could beat
the supervised top line like for me it
was a top line but we could approach it
but not beat it
and when we started to beat those
numbers it was very puzzling to me
and i i don't fully understand this so i
i cannot have like
an answer but
yeah maybe it's something about the task
like maybe our task is more
i don't know more generic and then
labels prediction maybe there is some
like we know that the
imagenet labels they are not perfect for
example sometimes you have an image of
i don't know i have this image in my
head but there is an image in imagenet
with an apple and a banana and the label
is
like banana and if the network has
output
apple then it just say no you're wrong
so
you know you have this kind of
imperfection about imagenet and maybe
like that's uh as that's
why uh like we are able to beat
the the label prediction task
with an unsupervised objective i've had
the same hypothesis
in that if you have a labeled objective
what you're saying is you're basically
giving the prototype
and you're basically saying that every
single sample of that class is an equal
representative of that prototype
whereas if you have the clustering
self-supervised approach
what you're doing is your base you're
saying no this
these few samples right here they are
more
representative of that class and these
are less and and that
allows you to generalize better because
you'll just
these outliers you just won't give them
as much weight
and if your you know your clustering
task is so aligned with the
classification task that
might be an explanation i had the
last question from me looking at your
formula of these cluster assignments you
know it's a
it's a dot product between two things
and then a soft max over it
do you see any connection to attention
mechanisms um in this and it would it be
what can we can we imagine an
architecture that doesn't do these
assignments once but
successively maybe in like a
hierarchical transformation you know do
the clustering
in this layer and then like a
transformer do it layer by layer
uh the same thing have you explored any
connection to that
no i haven't i haven't explored that
direction at all but
i i definitely agree with you like if
you look
at the formula it's very similar to
attention and you
and i think there is definitely
something to do there
but yeah i'm just a second year phd
student i have never played
with a transformer yet
so i i guess i cannot really give you
insights
about it yeah
cool but that's definitely uh something
that i would like to to try
a final thought from my end uh just to
expand what
janik uh suggested as to why
the unsupervised variants
kind of beat their supervised
counterparts
i think in supervised learning when you
you know make the approximation uh
problem very rigid that we are trying to
only map
images to their labels this kind of
approximation
i find this kind of approximations to be
very rigid enough
this might be the case that it's not
allowing the model to
be very free flowing about learning the
semantics
within the images but when you are you
know dealing
dealing in self-supervised regimes you
are
making the learning problem a bit more
free-flowing
you are relaxing or relaxing it a bit
that's why it's probably allowing the
model to you know exploit
uh the semantic understanding uh within
the images
more than your supervised variants so
just to expand one
what but just just to expand on what
yannick
jannik thinks about as to why uh
why unsupervised variants might beat
their
supervised counterparts
that would be my reasoning my final
thought would be that it's a really
great paper and all our viewers should
at least take some time out and give a
read to this paper
definitely fantastic well um on that
note
uh matilda and ayush and sayak
thank you so much for joining us today
um
the paper is absolutely amazing and and
it's it's so inspiring to see folks like
you pushing the state of the art and
computer vision and it's also inspiring
to see folks like sayak and ayush
making this uh you know accessible
democratizing machine learning for
anyone i think anyone on the internet
can can learn
uh machine learning and make serious
progress on this so
um i know that if folks want to reach
out to iosh and psych
you guys hang out on the weights and
biases slack channel and uh
matilda i'm not sure where you hang out
on the internet but people do you have a
twitter account
no okay you're uh
you're off the grid yes
i'm old school okay
you can send me an email i try to reply
quite quickly fb.com
fantastic well um folks it's been an
amazing episode tune in next week we've
got alex coming on and we're going to be
talking about the kind of
machine learning that happened before
deep learning we're going to go back to
the
stone age and we're going to talk about
kernel methods it's going to be
it's going to be amazing so if you want
to learn about kernels and how they work
tune in next week
anyway thanks folks see you soon thank
you
thank you